[Musique]
dans cette édition du 24 mars un bon
curseur de la santé économique le salon
tech'innove 2022 s'est déroulée mercredi
au parc floral de paris une quinzaine
d'entreprises de saint quentin en
yvelines était de la partie le rendez
vous de l'innovation a permis de
confirmer la reprise en ile-de-france
après des mois de crise due à la
pandémie une session de recrutement
originale elle était au programme
aujourd'hui à montigny le bretonneux
quand il a et recruteurs se sont
retrouvés ce matin pour une séance de
rugby en tout anonymat l'après midi
s'est poursuivi avec des entretiens dans
gauche une journée organisée par pôle
emploi ile de france et la ligue de
rugby francilienne et puis les
championnats scolaires et académiques
d'échecs se sont tenues cette semaine à
coignières environ 150 jeunes se sont
affrontés autour des damiers tous rêvé
d'une chose une qualification pour les
championnats de france
[Musique]
le conseil municipal de plaisir perturbé
hier mercredi les élus se réunissaient
pour approuver le bilan de la
concertation de la transformation du
vally bout en éco-quartier environ 30 à
40 personnes pour la plupart mineurs
sont venus taper contre les vitres de la
salle du conseil municipal
des gestes d'intimidation dont un
simulacre dégorgement avec le pouce ont
été proférées à l'encontre de là mère
joséphine coleman ce berger elle a
décidé de porter plainte dans un
communiqué les deals condamne ces
menaces et affirme que la municipalité
ne se découragera pas sur ce projet de
rénovation du vally bout l'élu se dit
ouverte au dialogue démocratique et
constructif
[Musique]
plus de 15000 rendez-vous et 2000
participants à tech'innove un signe que
la reprise économique a bien signé son
retour dans le monde de l'innovation
pour cette édition 2022 le territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines était bien
représenté avec une quinzaine de
sociétés venues chercher des
opportunités
tech'innove nous permet vraiment de nous
mettre en avant fin nous permet d'avoir
de la visibilité dans notre domaine et
de montrer aussi notre hyper expertise
dans le domaine une raisons de
visibilité sachant que nous sommes très
fortement focalisée sur l'innovation les
phases amont
des projets de r&d tech'innove orné dans
l'innovation on est dans un autre
élément en fait et puis ça nous permet
de rencontrer la plupart de nos futurs
clients de nos prospects organisé par la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie
paris-ile-de-france tech'innove est une
journée de business à travers des rendez
vous plusieurs secteurs d'activité
représentés medtech transformation
numérique environnement et défense et
sécurité au cours de cet événement start
à pme grands groupes et investisseurs se
rencontrent il n'y a rien de tel pour
identifier des projets
définir de nouveaux projets entre
certains pys novembre qui a sorti une
brique et un donneur d'ordre qui va
pouvoir lui confier des travaux et
plus si affinités si la preuve de
concept fonctionne cet événement faisait
son grand retour en présentiel après une
édition 2010 21 ans distant ciel en
pleine crise sanitaire
[Musique]
délivrer la bonne passe est trop soutien
de son coéquipier tout cela sans les
fameux plaquage demandeurs d'emploi et
recruteurs ont été plongés dans le monde
du rugby sans savoir qui est qui ils ont
participé à des ateliers notamment des
exercices pour la touche d'une dizaine
d'ateliers et progressivement ils
apprennent à travailler ensemble autour
de consignes qui sont données par les
techniciens là on fait une touche avec
un sauteur et quatre releveurs donc il
faut vraiment qu'ils apprennent à se
coordonner à travailler ensemble à
sélectionner qui va lever qui va
renvoyer la balle qui va sauter au coeur
de cette journée organisée à montigny le
bretonneux la ligue ile de france de
rugby et pôle emploi des conseillers
pôle emploi mêler aux participants dans
cette agence sportive d'une journée ils
ont pu se faire leur propre avis dans un
schéma atypique tout comme les
demandeurs d'emploi il ya les gens qui
courent sur le ballon qui tombe avec qui
n'ont pas peur de se faire mal il y
avait un peu plus timorés un peu plus
éloignés mais les suiveurs il ya les
lady doll est leader et puis un moment
donné il ya des gens qui se révèle
qu'ils sont un peu suiveurs et qui
prennent un petit peu le l'ascendant
donc c'est assez intéressant aussi c'est
très bien surtout pour le niveau social
parce qu'il ya des sur cinq personnes
des fois il
ils sont plutôt renfermés sur eux-mêmes
et peut-être aujourd'hui ça leur a servi
de
2,2 des preuves ça oblige à écouter les
autres et à les regarder les observer et
à s'adapter je pense que ça c'est
important quand on va chercher un emploi
au japon à savoir qui sont les
recrutements dans l'armée parce qu'ils
sont très en avant dire ouais on peut
faire ça on peut faire ça donc c'est
très bien parce que bah ça peut nous
aider pour les stratégies tout sonne que
j'ai un peut repérer dans l'après-midi
les masques tombent les recruteurs et
les candidats sont identifiés pour eux
un seul objectif trouver la nouvelle
recrue pour les entreprises où le
travail recherché pour les demandeurs
d'emploi et ainsi réaliser un grand
chelem de l'emploi
[Musique]
un cliché de martyn williams team
manager et légendes de la sélection
galloise de rugby et de françois de
mazières maire de versailles pour
officialiser cette nouvelle la ville
sera le camp de base du pays de galles
pour la prochaine coupe du monde de
rugby 2023 l'événement se déroulera en
france du 8 septembre au 28 octobre
pendant quatre semaines et demie le
quinze du poireau résidera dans la cité
royale et s'entraînera à porchefontaine
le complexe héberge au quotidien le
rugby-club de versailles le pays de
galles sera dans la poule d du mondial
avec l'australie et les fidji la géorgie
et l'uruguay
[Musique]
je m'appelle david j'ai 53 ans je suis
policier municipal responsable d'un
service de police une douzaine de
personnes
je fais ce métier depuis trente trois
ans maintenant mois principalement c'est
de gérer de futures visites organisées
les missions de la police municipale
après l'émission plus générale c'est
d'être sur le terrain de convenir de de
veiller à la tranquillité et à la
sécurité de notre commune
[Musique]
des attentes il y en a beaucoup mais
j'ai franchement j'en attends pas
beaucoup n'ont pas beaucoup parce que ça
fait des années et des années qu'on nous
fait des promesses
je parle comme l'encadrement pour mon
métier ça fait des années qu'on nous
fait des promesses et
mais trente trois ans j'ai jamais rien
vu venir à part des
alourdissement de compétences mes
attentes c'est une vraie prise en
considération de la police municipale
conçoit pas des fois on nous dit qu'on
est la troisième force
public mais dans l'est dans les actes
il y a
malheureusement on ressent un
désintéressement l'augmentation de nos
prérogatives qui nous permet maintenant
de faire beaucoup de choses ça c'est
clair mais
malheureusement le volet social il n'a
pas beaucoup augmenté
comparé nos collègues
du côté de la population genre à marie
et
notre retraite et les modiques eux
une carrière complète
dans policiers ont par terriblement avec
1300 ou 1400 euros de retraite dans
l'est dans les meilleurs moments
[Musique]
ils ont tous avancer leurs pions pour
tenter de s'emparer du roi de leurs
adversaires ce mercredi 24 mars ces
parties étaient organisées à coignard à
l'occasion des championnats scolaires
académique d'échec dans la salle une
centaine de joueurs de 6 à 15 ans venus
de toute l'académie de versailles on a
une partie du genre de club donc c'est
des équipes de 8 2 les premiers
échiquiers sont souvent des idées des
joueurs expérimentés et les derniers
échecs et sondé vraiment des enfants qui
ont découvert les échecs sur le temps
scolaire et qui découvrent la
compétition parmi ces rois de la
stratégie des yvelinois des écoles de
coignières encore ce collège de montfort
l'amaury étaient qualifiés pour ce
championnat ces joueurs fout de ce jeu
de plus le plus jeune âge est très à
cheval sur les règles ont leurs
techniques pour devenir les futurs
maîtres de cette discipline il faut
beaucoup d'entraînement il faut lier
beaucoup de livres dessus et faut
surtout bon sans beaucoup d'entraînement
c'est ce qui est le plus important est
bien connaître les règles le but c'est
pas de devenir force et de s'amuser en
jouant et c'est comme ça justement qu on
devient fort et on s'entraînant et en
faisant des défaites parce que c'est là
c'est la voie pour gagner les vainqueurs
des écoles se sont qualifiés pour la
grande finale nationale programmée à
brissac dans l'hérault la compétition
sera organisée en juin prochain il reste
donc un peu de temps pour réviser ses
stratégies
[Musique]
au bout des ondes un radio amateur
américain communiqué que le monde entier
c'est le terrain de jeu des adhérents du
radio club de montigny un jeu sérieux et
très encadrés ils ont tous un indicatif
un radio amateur c'est une personne qui
a
une attirance pour les
communications
par radio et aussi pour les technologies
l'électronique l'informatique la
mécanique et qui souhaite donc échangé
par radio avec d'autres radios amateurs
proches ou plus loin lancé en
1974 le club s'adapte en fonction de
l'évolution des technologies mais aussi
des compétences de chaque radio amateur
le radio club fait aussi de la formation
auprès des futurs passionnés et organise
des conférences on a eu l'idée de faire
une conférence sur une parabole qui est
à la cité des sciences de la villette
qui a été prise en charge par un groupe
de radio amateur il ya au moins une
douzaine d'années et c'est une parabole
gigantesque villa de fait 10 mètres de
diamètre cette parabole a été restaurée
et permet de faire de la radio
astronomie de lait coûte donc d'onde qui
viennent de l'espace les locaux unis
montrent un héberge l'adrasec et des
amateurs au service de la sécurité
civile
la radio est un outil pour la sécurité
et en k2 en cas de crise et tous et nous
radio matters certains mettent à
disposition leurs matériels leurs
compétences leur temps à leurs moyens
pour apporter un soutien supplémentaire
aux
la sécurité civile ils sont 70 adhérents
à se réunir chaque semaine pour partager
leur passion utilisation des conditions
climatiques du morse du système wifi et
même de la lune les radioamateurs sont
des touche-à-tout
[Musique]
avant de refermer ce journal attention
si vous avez prévu d'emprunter les
transports en commun demain vendredi un
préavis de grève a été déposé par les
principaux syndicats à la ratp pour
défendre les conditions de travail dans
le cadre de l'ouverture à la concurrence
pour les prévisions le trafic sera
fortement perturbé sur le réseau des bus
et tramways comptez un tram sur 2 aux
heures de pointe sur le t6 qui passe par
vélizy villacoublay et viroflay le
trafic sera en revanche normal sur les
rer a et b sur la plupart des lignes de
métro à paris restez informés sur le
site de la ratp belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]